what's happening there reject nation
thank you so much for clicking on this
video we are going to watch this new
trailer from marvel entertainment moon
knight featurette apparently has a lot
of new footage some new information if
you could leave a like that would be
amazing let's watch
[Music]
the fun of moon night is getting
introduced to a new superhero in a new
world
it's a real legitimate character study
i can't tell a difference
between my waking life
and dreams
moon knight is a spectacular character's
got an incredibly unique visual look
yeah
our job was to kind of put a lens on the
things that had the most uh dramatic
juice and ultimately take the mental
health aspect incredibly seriously
that's good
stephen
the way we're tackling the story we
learn about steven and then learn about
mark what's wrong with you mark
why did you call me mo interesting and
they're the same person
okay
the tone is like fight club meets
indiana jones
to tie it into something so vast and
supernatural it's amazing
thank you
every aspect of this show
for you we've shifted the paradigm
for me what's really exciting is that
it's totally unpredictable
dope
i love it
got a lot of thoughts here gotta get
that jump across the way
you know when they said it's like fight
club meets indiana jones it really
really clicked for me right then and
there because i mean if you've seen
fight club spoilers here if you have you
seen it yet i know all about fight club
at this point all right if you haven't
seen fight club click off now you find
out that edward norton actually has a
split personality and that is brep it's
tyler durden and then when you're
watching this you're like oh it's all
dealing with all kinds of personalities
here and then what's real what isn't did
i do this did i not do this combining
like fight club and indiana jones it all
just went oh yeah that that's it that's
what i'm seeing that's all i've been
seeing this whole time i didn't even
realize it which is cool because it was
like you're mixing with the
archaeological adventures and whatnot
and what i took away that i thought was
really fascinating that when they were
talking about uh stephen grant right at
the front is that it doesn't seem like
that we're going to be starting off this
series with mark spector and konju in
egypt that we will eventually go back
there and uncover the origins kind of
like how the netflix series would do it
where you started off in the middle of
something or where this character is
currently at and then eventually we'll
do an episode where you see the origin
but rather than just some flashback
it'll be a journey for the character of
stephen grant where stephen graham we're
going to start off with him which is a
personality derived from all these
experiences he's going to be uncovering
like oh my god i'm not really stephen
grant i'm actually mark spector which
adds more mystery and revelations to it
all which which i think is really great
but i know you're really excited for
ethan hawk so want to touch on that a
little bit of what he was saying oh i
mean absolutely i love that he's talking
about yeah the duality here that is
perfectly represented in both yeah the
mixture of tones the mixture of all
these different characters colliding
together and for him i mean you know the
arthur harrow character is a small you
know kind of one-off character in the
comics and i'm excited to see what he
brings because in the first ad you know
we see him looking like a more sinister
cult leader whereas here it actually
seems like he has more of this like
profit quality almost that brief glimpse
of him holding what looks like a scarab
beetle and there's some kind of magical
presence there they said uh they they
said uh you know fight club and indiana
jones but i also thought of the mummy uh
most definitely and you know being that
they want to hone in on the psychology
and really honor all that stuff you know
i am really excited to see an actor with
as much credibility and as great of a
pedigree as ethan hawk go up against
oscar isaac because ethan hawke i mean
he's been around
a good while longer and to see him step
into a world like this you know they
always talk up how oh it's going to be
an excellent character study and it's
going to be action-packed it's going to
have everything you want but i really
believe that coming from these actors
and this show and i'm really excited to
see how yeah they play off one another
and how they honor yeah the harsher
aspects of uh just the mental uh states
involved because obviously i mean you've
got the split personalities of mark
specter steven grant etc but there's got
to be more to what the arthur hero
character is as well what is his duality
and what kind of debate or struggle is
going to come out of him and i love too
you know seeing these greater glimpses
into what looks like the more magical
and the more mystical you get this
pyramid with the electricity sparking
off the top or these big rings that
almost look you know galactic in a way
but also clearly of a mystical origin
what he said about duality really rings
through this whole thing
and i'm excited to see those new shades
that they bring in for yeah the
mysticism but also the darkness that
lies underneath all that stuff
i'm curious how they will handle the
mental health aspect because in all
honesty they're making mental health
struggles look [ __ ] awesome
and so i think there's a fine line you
could write there where it's like you
really have to capture the struggle very
much so because as compelling as awesome
as this looks um it's really easy
especially with characters with did to
go into that's cool or that's hor or
like that's a cool horror movie you know
yeah you know and so if they can
actually do something where there's a
commentary that treats it with a level
of sensitivity that would be probably
the biggest accomplishment they could
pull off because that seems like the
hardest thing you can do when plugging
your marvel disney plush show you know
that's what i'm most curious about and i
really hope they can nail because did
has become this sort of genre trope at
this point which is a bit reductive and
if they could nail a great character
study based off that and have all the
cool stuff too like that would be so
gratifying let's just hope they can
actually
pull it off in the end so it's going to
be like weirdly structured and uh you
know kevin feige talking about its
unique aesthetic and palette i feel like
this will be more
the closest so far to what is akin to
the actual netflix series but on a more
heightened supernatural level because
obviously we're going to be going to
egypt we've been dealing with kanji
we're dealing a lot of these mystical
creatures and whatnot and some like you
know legendary egyptian characters
perhaps but we'll see guys what did you
think about this moon knight first look
uh we're behind the scenes actually not
the first look leave your thoughts down
below subscribe click that like button
and hey let's do a patron of the day
shout out
vlev doran flev uh i want to shout you
out here eh because marvel you like
being shout out on marvel videos and b
i'm pretty confident that out of anyone
at our patreon page as we do all those
shows over there and i'm pretty
confident that anyone at our patreon
page
who watches pretty much all we cover
it's you i like i don't think you watch
every single one of them but i think you
got the leg up on the most
like you comments honest taste broadest
taste you comment on a variety of ones
so dude i want to thank you for just
being one of our most loyal supporters
we've ever had and you're always leaving
such positivity in the comment boxes for
us you are a motivation you are
encouragement i know we always usually
make some like stupid ass joke when we
we talk about you flap but this time
around i just wanted to say thank you
for being awesome thank you for being
you and thank you for consistently not
just showing your support with your
hard-earned dollars but also showing
your support by actually giving us
feedback and interacting with us on a
daily basis youthbomb.com thank you
buddy
[Music]